a relationship is a friendship as well
you get to know somebody's life and his
family and their soul and things right
and you fall in love with not just the
sexuality right well with all of it did
you want to have kids and stuff
you want to have kids yeah I did but
then somewhere somewhere the story got
twisted and it's like I'm the one who
didn't want kids but I want kids don't
twist I'm not gonna don't twist the
shoulders no but I want at the end of
our relationship I believe I believe her
I believe her but I don't as well so she
wanted kids you didn't want kids for
that yeah let's just say because
honestly I feel like 10 years that
you're right you're the biggest head of
Chinese person I've ever seen like I've
never seen however your wife yeah
metaphorically or like actually
physically literally literally a big
head yeah it's a seven and five Ace yo
you know yes
that's big big
there's bigger no for Chinese I think
for Chinese I think it's pretty big
because Koreans usually have we have the
big heads is what I'm saying my bad my
bad 23andMe said I got like some blood
from northern China Korea my mom's from
their families there we go dude what's
up dude yeah so right straight up got
that like big Bodega head yeah yeah what
about my head my head Discount Liquor I
think right now this guy
yeah but how much of his neck are you
counting yeah yeah but that's also uh he
has a tumor right like it's some type of
like lymph issue yeah it's like
lymphedema I can't even laugh at him oh
my God he's a pretty good great body
though just stop working out the neck
I think that's the problem you know what
I mean we just put a waist trainer on
his neck maybe there's a neck yeah give
me these doing yeah back to what you
were saying I think what I I
it would be really really hard if there
was a lot of romantic feelings still
there yeah hell yeah but I it's not it's
still not easy but I don't know like I
think
yeah I've been listening just to be like
damn they're doing breakups so well yeah
yeah man we are I also um
we also have tigerbell we gotta do yeah
about your money it's not about money no
no oh you got it wrong pal really yeah
Chicho all right listen to me Amigo yeah
all right you not about your money
listen to me man okay
tigerbelly is our baby yeah
so we did have kids oh wow and we're
taking care of the space do you see the
face you just made
I bite my lips
I wanted a real baby eggs
yeah
I think this is our thing we created
right and it's grown to this if we when
we do live shows people come out I feel
like our children come out yeah right
and it's a gigantic extended family and
this feels like a baby to me it is cute
like I'm gonna do a podcast with my girl
because I like I like this yeah it's
cool right you guys are like the better
looking version of tigerbelly oh my God
they're the hot us no we're not we're
just together
[Laughter]
there's something that doesn't seem
right but it is right
right yeah yeah yeah it doesn't seem but
it's like her man should be a foot
taller
she's giving my man should be a foot
but can I just say though this photo I
love this photo yeah this is you know
what this is called this he was just
called [__] winning
you're winning dude thank you of course
she's going out with you your Dynamic
special you're creative your man you're
[__] not lazy you got a big head
etc etc dude but you got everything dude
yeah your stylist thank you right thank
you you can cook right you got it all
dude
congratulations brother